Now that we understand what some of the foliage settings do, let's dig into foliage types
and what you have access to here.
So there's three main foliage types.
We have the active foliage, the landscape grass type, and the static mesh foliage.
So foliage types allow you to make presets that can be then used as bases for other types
of foliage.
So foliage types are made from and stored inside the content browser.
So you can see these little icons here.
That means they have some kind of data asset that belongs in the content browser.
And then each type is for a specific interaction type.
So kicking off with active foliage here, the active foliage is if you want the foliage
to be interacted with.
The landscape grass type is for densely populated landscape grass.
And then the static mesh foliage is for any static or non-interactive foliage you would
like to use.
So looking at these foliage types here, if you want to run a blueprint on your foliage,
then active foliage is what you'd need to use.
It works just like any other foliage type, but it has an input for a blueprint actor,
which you can see in the details panel here that can then be used to spawn from it.
So it allows you to use the same tools, but scatter, say 100 or 1000 of it, an interactive
object instead of having to hand place them individually.
Then if you can see from this image here, you can see an example of that working.
So the box in front of the use, the player will trigger an event when the user goes in
and out. So we'll go in and out of this box.
And then the boxes where the painted landscape are using the foliage tool.
Then with the landscape grass type, this grass tool is used to densely cover the landscape,
as we said before. So you can cover the landscape terrain with things like grass or flowers
and small rocks. And you don't need to paint the area, but instead define where the grass
should spawn based on which landscape layer is visible.
So you can also specify things like density and offsets to allow for a variety of different
looking grasses here.
And then to show a setup here.
So the grass tool allows you to add thousands of static meshes to the landscape to help
simulate what grass will look like.
So with the grass tool, you can add grass to the entire landscape or just specific landscape
layers, like we said. So you can also use it to control the density in the distance
at which the grass will render.
So there's some optimization settings there.
And then for this type of setup to work, you would need to add the landscape grass type,
which is where the static meshes are used for the grass.
And they're defined there.
You can have more than one static mesh in a single grass type.
So that should be noted there.
So if we have landscape grass type, then we'd also want landscape grass output.
And that is this material expression here.
And it's the material expression node, which essentially just tells the landscape actor
which layer you should have the grass placed on.
So you can also have a number of different grass types in your material.
And then the mesh used does not have to be grass, as we said before, it could be any kind of
mesh or material you want to use there.
So you can use it to display rocks and bushes and flowers and small trees, as we said previously.
And then lastly, covering the static mesh foliage type.
So with the foliage type, we can use static mesh foliage types with the foliage paint tool.
So you can just see the paint settings here.
So each foliage type you add can be painted using this tool.
So nice and straightforward.